I'm sorry escaping I'm a visual artist I
paint I sculpt I'm known by designing I
design I wear with trash this one I call
it from the desktop computer I call it
the father boot this one I call it a big
mouth the speaker's the computers
because
when you walk in town when you see
someone wearing my glasses the glasses
who take all the attention if you have
any stress between like a Tara when I
was young I used to admire the real
glasses but my dad was a bit harsh
he never like wanted me to of the real
glasses that's there is on why I started
reading the glasses I really love trust
I try to be trash a second chance I
change it to be something else which is
like it will stay more than 100 years
now the most dangerous waste that will
miss our continent our here is its
electronics we need to think how we can
stop making more matter we need to
recycle them we need to change our
mentality we need to be creative with my
artwork is a lot about accumulation
maybe